ومع الان مباشره من اسطنبول ومن شارع
الاستقلال تحديدا مراسل كات حسين اسد حسين
صباح الخير واهلا بك معنا حسين اذا
السلطات التركيه تحدد الجهه التي تقف
بحسبها وراء هذا الهجوم وتوجه اصابع
الاتهام الى مسلحين اكرم
بعد ان افتتح مره اخرى امام العامه عدد
كبير من السياح والسكان المحليين جاءوا
الى موقع الحادث لالقاء نظره على المكان
وايضا لقاء الزهور تحدثنا الى بعض السياح
كانوا يشعرون بالحزن كما قالوا لنا فيما
لا تزال الصدمه سائده على شهود العيان من
العاملين في المكان وزير الداخليه سليمان
سولو اكد اعتقال المجتمع فيها الاولى في
هذا الهجوم وهي سيده سوريه اسمها احلام
البشير يعتقد انها جاءت من عفرين دخلت الى
تركيا وظلت لفتره مختلفه قبل ان تنفذ هذا
الهجوم عبر حقيبه همم
تركتها على احدى المقاعد هنا في جده
الاستقلال القلب النابض في اسطنبول وايضا
تم اعتقال اكثر من 45 شخصا يعتقد بانهم
على صله بهذا الهجوم وزير الداخليه سليمان
سولو اتهم حزب العمال الكردستاني في
الضلوع في هذا الهجوم وايضا توعد بان يكون
الرد التركي قاسيا على هذا الهجوم اتهم
بشكل غير مباشر الولايات المتحده وحملها
المسؤوليه عن هذا الهجوم باعتبار انها
الداعم الرئيسي للمقاتلين الاكراد وحدات
الحمايه الكرديه التي تقول الداخليه
التركيه انها اعطت التعليمات من كوباني
لتنفيذ هذا الهجوم في اسطنبول الهجوم الذي
اودى في حياته سته اشخاص على الاقل واصابه
اكثر من 80 همم حتى هذه اللحظه هي الحصيله
الرسميه التي اعلنتها السلطات التركيه
اشكرك يا حسين على كل هذه الحسين الاسد
مراسل مباشره من شارع الاستقلال في
اسطنبول